this
looks good to me and
I was gonna say don't bite your face and
then I just put my face in it
hey what's up it's toy and welcome to
making it big the show where my friends
challenged me to make their favorite
foods big so you might notice that my
table here is a little warped and that's
because we're filming everything in VR
you can watch the full VR episode with a
meta Quest 2 in mega tasty that's our
virtual cooking world within Horizon
worlds or on metaquest TV today I have a
very special guest it's Miss Asia
Jackson
hi welcome to the show thank you so much
for having me how are you today I'm good
how are you I am kind of nervous right
now kind of nervous yeah as you should I
I just don't know what you're gonna
challenge me to and I feel like you are
very particular so I really have to nail
this yes absolutely yeah so let's see it
all right here we go
[Music]
oh wow yes Vietnamese egg roll
Vietnamese egg rolls look at that okay
so explain to me why Vietnamese egg
rolls so I'm half Filipino we have our
own egg roll version yeah we call it
lumpia but it's such a staple in East
and Southeast Asia so I was like have
her show us how to make a gigantic
Vietnamese egg roll no what about sauce
do you want a dipping sauce on the side
yeah yeah okay I actually have a special
sauce I make for my egg rolls so if you
don't mind I can make that for you yeah
I'd love to try it I have a lot of work
to do
I will see you later all right girl
thanks friend I put my trust in you
[Music]
let's get to it
first things first the wrapper when I
make egg rolls I usually just use the
wrapper from the store but we couldn't
find any that was big enough so I have
my flower here I am going to add in some
salt I'm adding hot water just so it can
hydrate the dough
there's been some debate between if this
is an egg roll or a spring roll but you
know what to me this is a Jaya that
means
Egg Roll in Vietnamese
[Music]
I love playing with dough
[Music]
cut this in my bowl and let it rest for
30 minutes
so the reason why I needed this dough to
rest is because I need the glue in to
just calm down a little bit or else I
won't be able to spread them out as thin
as I would like to
[Music]
foreign
thickness for the egg roll 2. so yeah I
am going to let this wrapper rest in the
fridge
just so when I fill it up with the
filling it can stay the shape see you
later
[Music]
so now I'm going to combine my minced
pork the shrimps the onions see all
these different texture that's going in
it's really going to give it a nice
mouth feel when you bite into it the
carrots the noodles
the mushrooms
egg yolks hence
egg rolls green onions minced garlic
and there's already a lot of flavors in
here but we do need to add seasoning
because you need to season your food
sesame oil
just a little bit because this is really
overpowering my favorite thing in the
whole entire world
fish sauce
it's a replacement for salt but it also
adds that like nice umami
touch to it when you bite into something
that's been seasoned with fish sauce you
know that it's not just been seasoned
with salt it's been seasoned with love
so we have sugar here
pepper
[Applause]
are you ready because I am
whoa nice massage don't you wish you can
just get in here with me here you go
this is our filling
rolled many egg rolls in my life I have
never ruled one this big let's do this
[Music]
oh
let's close
and everything is nice and tight I have
my egg wash here
[Music]
fold it over oh
[Music]
all right
I think
I'm ready
yes
wow
and this
is my Giant Egg Roll I hope that you
cook all the way through
if you don't you are a disappointment
[Music]
let's get this in the fryer
[Music]
welcome to the back kitchen so I have my
Jaya here the fryer is over there as you
can see the friendly fry guy is here
I am going to say my butt right over
here because that's 10 gallons of hot
oil that I'm kind of scared of
so I'm gonna hand this over to you drop
that egg roll
[Music]
all right I'll see you in two hours
bye friend
[Music]
so my baby is in the fryer so that gives
me time to make the sauce usually I like
to eat my egg rolls with mapoya sweet
chili sauce but this is my recipe so
we'll call it toy POI I have some Fresno
chilies here that I'm just going to give
a rough chop and then I have some Thai
chilies over here bird's eye chilies
okay I have my garlic over here more
garlic the better
this
looks good to me now I was gonna stand
up on your face again I just put my face
up
[Music]
liftball
[Music]
okay moment of truth I'm about to bring
Asia in but I just want to take a quick
moment to just really take it all in
because I really did just make a giant
egg roll look at this this
compared to this
[Music]
hopefully she likes it Asia please come
in
[Music]
heck oh my God this is huge the big
giant egg roll that you asked for how
much does this weigh it actually weighs
15 pounds it is 16 inches long and 6
inches wide we ready
[Music]
oh my gosh
this is so heavy you guys have no idea
okay
[Music]
first oh I think you're the guest the
guest thank you so oh my God okay
[Music]
spice warning it might be a little spicy
okay disclaimer you guys I have a very
low spice tolerance so okay maybe over
there and then you can get a lick over
here no I'm just gonna go for it all
right
I warned her
we got we got that on camera right okay
okay okay ready yup one two three
honestly this is really good
well there you go hmm my Giant Egg Roll
was a success oh and the sauce is really
good too really it's not that spicy it's
not too spicy okay we'll see about that
okay just wait
in the comments below let me know what I
should make big next and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
my hand is cramping because this is so
heavy
[Music]